sommes nous en direct avec marisa
garnier couturière bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
pourquoi cet appel au gouvernement le
collectif bas les masques donc qui
interpelle les autorités
c'était au départ du bénévolat ça se mue
progressivement au travail gratuit pour
quelles raisons bonsoir
alors c'est vrai que au démarrage lors
du démarrage lors du début du
confinement
on a été très nombreuses couturière à se
mobiliser pour fournir des masques aux
personnels soignants et aux travailleurs
de première ligne
c'est vrai que vu les manquements de
stocks on sait tout tout de suite en
parreno aiguilles et petit à petit
notamment à l'annonce du déconfinement
le 11 mai plus de plus en plus de
demandes soient arrivées plus seulement
des soignants mais vraiment en des
entreprises qu'ils allaient réouvrir
comme des particuliers qui voulaient se
protéger eux et leur famille
et là ont commencé à venir énormément de
demandes des demandes plus ou moins
compréhensible ou agressive envers les
couturières qui qu'ils n'acceptaient pas
forcément de faire du travail 100%
gratuit pour tout le monde car à
l'origine c'était quand même pour plus
pour subvenir aux demandes des
personnels soignants et ensuite ça s'est
vraiment énormément étendue et l'idée
c'est quand même de pouvoir pallier au
manque de masques dans l'urgence mais
pas que je ne mets pas que ça devienne
quelque chose de normal et d' accessible
à tous alors justement qu'attendez vous
clairement aujourd'hui du gouvernement
vous l'avez interpellé qu'est ce qu'il
vous a répondu
alors écoutez moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
connaissance d'une réponse à ce jour
mais mais a minima ce qui ce qui serait
intéressant d'avoir c'est déjà le
remboursement des matières premières
utilisées par toutes les couturières
bénévoles car lors du confinement on a
tout utiliser nos stocks personnel nos
machines à domicile machine familiale ou
machine ou machines industrielles pour
celle qui avait la chance d'en avoir
chez elle et tout ça ça représente quand
même une somme non négligeable pour pour
les indépendantes des tpe ou des
freelances du monde du costume et du
spectacle ou de du textile en général
donc déjà ça c'est un premier poupon un
pouvoir se faire rembourser toutes ces
matières qui ont été longs et et donner
bénévolement et ensuite ce sera
intéressant en effet de pouvoir
comptabiliser les heures qui ont été
passées car on a tout passé des
centaines d'heures à créer des masques
et à les offrir gracieusement
donc voilà soit en salaire soit il ya
dix ans il ya plein d'autres
propositions qui sont faites sur par le
collectif lors de l'appel
mais voilà c'est vraiment les rues dans
les premières revendications aujourd'hui
clairement quand on vous sollicitera
puisque j'ai compris que on le fait
beaucoup et avec parfois insistance
telle sera votre réponse
alors après dans dans le monde textile
il ya énormément de cas de figure
différent il ya des personnes qui
travaillent en société et qui pour
l'instant sont en chômage partiel à
domicile il ya des personnes qui ont des
tpe il ya des freelances il ya des
personnes qui travaillent pour dans le
monde du spectacle donc ça chaque
couturière et couturiers de mettre ses
propres règles pour ma part moi je suis
une créatrice indépendante et j'ai à
coeur de pouvoir offrir des masques de
manière de manière solidaire à tout le
monde donc pour l'instant ma règle c'est
des masques les masques que classique en
coton qui suivent les recommandations
qui ont été faites notamment par l'afnor
je les propose à prix libre pour chacun
maintenant même même ce prix libre créé
quand même débat et il ya une personne
qui ne comprennent pas que nous pouvons
offrir des masques gratuits pour tous
car nous avons la matière première à
acheter des frais sans même compter
notre eau notre taux horaire remercie en
tout cas marisa garnier je rappelle que
vous êtes couturière merci d'avoir été
en direct avec nous sur rt france et
c'est là